I made a comment in July that EDH has
effectively become the Casual way to
play Paper magic and it really has the
days of 60c card kitchen table gaming
are in the past replaced by a diverging
path for newer players either play Arena
and get your 1 V one fix from the
comfort of your couch or meet up with
three other people and play Commander
the nostalgic part of me certainly wants
to push back on this and I've spoken
before about some of the reasons why
Commander perhaps isn't the best onramp
for newer players but there are also
some clear upsides to Commander the fact
that it's a casual format by designation
rather than being casual gameplay on the
fringes of competitive formats means a
much greater degree of stability than
something like 60 card kitchen table
magic a format whose current form
basically vanishes off the face of the
Earth whenever the friends who want to
play it with you stop wanting to play it
more importantly Commander as a format
clearly isn't going anywhere in the
Casual scene so it's pointless to try
and fight against it that said the
collapse of 60 card casual magic along
with the slow decline in popularity of
draft that I've noticed over the last 10
years have had me thinking what are we
losing exactly what impact is it having
that there is a growing population of
Commander players who have played little
to none of other formats to be clear
this isn't intended as old man grumbling
I can certainly get old man grumbly
sometimes as somebody who has been
playing Magic for more than half of my
life and maybe I'd be more old man
grumbly if I were a modern player or
something but no this is a genuine
question and to get some insight into it
I'm going to answer a slightly different
set of questions in this video What is
the experience of playing formats that
aren't commander and DOW upon a player
what impact might that sort of
experience have on the way they play
commander and do these impacts make it
worth venturing outside EDH from time to
time for us primarily EDH players to
start with let's talk about the gameplay
experience of a 20 Health 1v1 format a
defining feature of these formats as
compared to Commander is that they're
low slung and grindy with smaller
threats being more relevant with this
fact in mind what I'm about to say may
initially seem a bit confusing that
being that playing these formats can
directly help with building the skills
required for playing commander commander
and 20 Health formats certainly are
different but counterintuitively this is
exactly why it can be helpful to have
played the latter it can give a player
breadth of experience see playing
Commander gives players lots of
experience in fighting against big
bombastic windc cons for starters you've
got the obvious examples like combo
decks and combo adjacent plays like a
massive xell or a crater hoof on a board
full of tokens plays that reduce one or
more life totals to zero in one fail
swoop and often do so with large
excesses of damage even outside of these
life total can frequently feel
Irrelevant in EDH regardless of whether
it is or not even with a conventional
big creatures mid-range deck without a
splashy singular finisher a lot of times
most damage will be dealt in one or two
attack swings this comes down to the
snowbally nature of a lot of EDH decks
all sorts of cards are intended to push
a deck to greater and greater volumes of
gameplay whether that be effect doublers
or Mana doublers or other forms of
action compounding engines
this often means that decks buckle down
until they have a massive Board of
creatures to attack with before swinging
wide sometimes for entire life totals in
one go somebody might have to count out
35 damage to this player 29 damage to
that player and so on and under that
context opponents don't even really need
to think about their life total
regardless of if a handful of points of
difference would have been relevant or
not like come on you lost because the
opponent popped off simple as however
what this means is that Commander
players are often less prepared for
grindar games where every point of life
total matters the results of this can be
seen when it comes to blocking and life
total management players who are more
experienced in formats where life totals
are relevant will be much more careful
of certain life total thresholds and
more willing to block to stay above them
players of 20 Health formats learn to
internalize the idea that life total is
a resource and to know when to spend and
when to save that resource but Commander
players who have spent a lot of time
dealing with bigger one or two shot Wing
consons won't internalize this lesson
nearly as quickly EDH is higher life
totals also train players to mostly
disregard the idea of blocking with
useful creatures because it feels better
to keep them around and most of the time
that's the correct decision in terms of
strategy as well unlike in a 20 Health
format where blocking with a key
creature to stay alive for an extra turn
or two is a very common necessity that
players get used to biting the bullet on
this isn't necessary nearly as often in
EDH due to higher life totals and
heftier wicon and this means that when
it becomes a necessity a lot of players
instinctually refuse to do it even when
it means sacrificing an amount of life
that will almost certainly lose them a
game another aspect of non-command
gameplay and particularly limited
formats is low resource environments
where players are topdecking or working
under tight constraints in some other
way these games aren't wildly common in
Commander due to how common ramp and
draw are with variation by play group
obviously and this means that you need
to play a lot more EDH to get
comfortable under these circumstances
than you would to get comfortable under
more common EDH scenarios the results of
this can be quite problematic when a
game has involved some form of stacks or
heavy attrition and resources are
dwindling you can usually tell who has
played other formats and who hasn't a
lot of primarily EDH players will be
looking at the situation as a lost cause
a game gone wildly off the rails whereas
players who have done their time in the
trenches of limited or 60 card formats
will be more engaged and Vigilant
looking for outs and bits of incremental
advantage to grab on to outside of
gameplay the experience of building 60
card decks can help with EDH deck
building as well one way this can
manifest is when building decks that are
exceptions to traditional Norms of EDH
deck building see people tend to have
rough templates they follow when they
build Commander decks myself included a
low double digit number of draw spells
is good for maintaining a consistent
stream of cards turn over turn maybe
more if those draw spells are smaller or
less if the deck has other ways to
compound value or tutors to find its
value engines likewise a low double
digits amount of ramp will be good for a
deck that wants to have a single piece
of ramp most games but is fine
occasionally not having one and
adjustments will be made up or down
depending on how often a deck wants ramp
what size of ramp a deck wants and how
aggressively a player is willing to
Mulligan these are references I follow
and I like them as a starting point
because they're flexible they prescribe
numbers of cards based on what a deck
wants to do and what other tools a deck
has available to it however the trouble
comes when references like these are
less flexible and when they're treated
as gospel regardless of what deck
they're being applied to ramp is a great
example for demonstrating this because
it's one of the biggest differences
between EDH and other formats basically
all EDH decks have some amount of ramp
in them and most have a decent amount 8
to 10 slots spent on ramp is common by
contrast most 60c card decks do not you
will get specific decks focused on high
cost plays such as Tron that focus a lot
of deck space on ramping and you'll get
mid-range Decks that run a spattering of
efficient dorks to hit their impactful
three four and five drops a turn early
in some games in order to gain a Tempo
Advantage broadly though ramp isn't
widely played in 60 card formats because
it often isn't worthwhile to expend a
card just for a bit of acceleration this
is likewise true in limited I'll run an
efficient dork like a lir elves and I'll
run a card like dance of the tumble
weeds or poison dart frog that has some
extra utility attached at a good rate
and occasionally I'll add some lesser
ramp if I have critical high cost plays
that my game plan ended up needing to
revolve around aside from these
instances though it's almost never
correct to play ramp in draft or sealed
draw is usually sparse and mana and
cards are better spent contesting the
board and threatening life totals the
result of all of this is that in
format's outside Commander ramp spells
are viewed very critically a player must
ask thems why is this here and if that
question doesn't have a clear and
persuasive answer the card will
generally get cut by contrast many
people building a commander deck will
throw together their template built EDH
Deck with the requisite count of ramp
cards picked from among the available
Staples these will often be added
without consideration for what the cards
are accomplishing you'll get cultivate
in two-color decks with a four Mana
Commander gilded lotus in decks with an
average Mana value of 2.5 rampant growth
in an artifact centered Deck with a
three Mana commander and so on
fundamentally the issue is that a lot of
players don't stop to consider what ramp
is offering them because they're playing
in a format where it is an
unquestionable fact of life I play ramp
because I want more mana come on now in
most decks this won't be the end of the
world decks do want ramp spells and even
if players add ramp that is a bit
sub-optimal for their deck their deck is
still spending slots on a thing that it
needs and the specifics can be corrected
later however just as there's Variety in
how much ramp 60 card decks want there
will be some Commander Decks that don't
really want ramp in any sort of
conventional quantities I have two
different decks where this is the case
in both my malagor deck and my Francisco
Malcolm deck I don't want to spend the
entirety of my turn two or three playing
ramp spells because I have more useful
cards I want to be developing both decks
include a handful of rocks for purposes
of weaving into a later turn because
this is still EDH we're talking about
and getting a future Mana boost off of a
one Mana investment is still useful for
keeping up in later turns but these
aren't really a key card type and each
deck only runs a low single digits
quantity of two Mana rocks so as not to
draw more than one in the early stages
of a game plus a soul ring to cash in on
my Wizards of the Coast mandated dose of
variance the step of asking how much
Mana a deck actually needs and what
times it will want to play ramp spells
is one that a lot of players forget to
complete and playing other formats where
the inclusion of ramp isn't such a
foregone conclusion is great for getting
perspective on what these cards are
actually accomplishing in a deck the
same can go for other card types when is
it correct to exclude or go light on
card draw when is it correct to exclude
board wipes these are things that EDH
players will consider Necessities but
depending on the deck they might not be
nearly as important as a player might
assume one other deck building skill
that EDH isn't great at teaching players
is figuring out optimal card quantities
a feature of Singleton formats is that
they restrict how many of a particular
sort of card a player can run some cards
will have many similar options but other
types of card will be more unique and a
player will have no choice but to add
the number of it that exist to the deck
and no more regardless of how much they
like it this outsources a lot of
decisionmaking to the nature of the
format players don't get to choose how
many cards to add to their deck that
create additional dragons when a dragon
attacks that decision is already made
for them whereas in 60 card formats up
to four of a given card can be run
giving players room to flex counts up
and down on various cards and see how
they feel in EDH there often isn't this
same level of choice the result of this
is that when players have access to a
greater number of a particularly
appealing effect if they've played EDH
but not other formats the Instinct might
be to load up on all available copies of
that effect regardless of how many would
actually be optimal for the deck this is
likely something that will be figured
out in due time so long as players are
willing to challenge their assumptions
about how their decks work from time to
time but having less of an intuitive
Sense on how many copies of a card is
appropriate is certainly something that
can lead to wasted time and games played
with an off-kilter deck long story short
yes playing formats outside EDH can
imbue players with important experiences
experiences that will be especially
useful on the fringes of the commander
experience Commander players will have
no trouble getting used to playing
against snowbally value piles dealing
with board wipes building conventional
Synergy based mid-range developing a
growing knowledge of common Staples and
so on playing lots of Commander will
make you better at a lot of things in
commander and playing enough commander
in diverse environments will even Grant
a degree of proficiency in the things I
mentioned earlier life total management
low resource environments unconventional
deck types and so on these certainly
aren't forbidden knowledge of anything
but playing formats outside EDH will
help to instill certain lessons faster
than others and develop an intuitive
sense for why they're true it's also
good to play other formats because cards
are designed for other formats and the
further back in time a card was printed
the more it was focused for 1 V one
formats as much as it can feel like
Commander players are playing in our own
little bubble we're playing with cards
that are part of a broader game and
having a better understanding of all the
facets of that game will help you as a
player across the board
if nothing else it's good to be aware of
the areas of play that we might be a bit
weaker in and try to gain experience in
them to wrap this up what formats should
you be playing as far as 60 card formats
go I can't really speak for the quality
of most of them because I simply haven't
played them recently with one exception
popper this all Commons format is cheap
to get into and pretty vibrant and its
fast-paced but not overly complex
gameplay makes it a great place to dive
into 60 card magic Switching gears to
limited my personal favorite way to play
Magic outside EDH is is draft and Cube
the process of drafting from packs and
deck building with the resulting pool is
a skill testing task all on its own that
will appeal to anybody who loves deck
building and also has a bit of a
competitive or Spike adjacent streak if
those two options sound too intimidating
if nothing else you should go to
pre-releases these are sealed events you
open six packs and build a deck with
them I personally prefer draft to sealed
but the exact reasons that make a
longtime player like me have this
preference make seal a great option for
players without as much experience
playing Limited building is more
streamlined and less punishing of
mistakes since decks can be totally
rebuilt between rounds if it becomes
clear something went wrong and variance
plays a greater role in success which
means that a less experienced player who
pulls the right selection of cards can
have a Fighting Chance even against a
magic veteran if you want to hear more
about why it's worth playing non-c
Commander formats and what formats you
should get into there's a whole episode
that just released on the podcast I
co-host that goes into more depth on
this and a link to that is in the
description with that said thanks for
watching and thanks to architect for
supporting the channel one of of my
favorite Parts about the site is the
visually streamlined folder system that
lets me keep my decks organized with
ease a link to my architect profile is
in the description if you want to browse
the various folders there and the decks
contained within as always I also want
to thank my patrons some of whom are on
screen now my final Deck review for the
year is taking submissions now so if you
want a chance at getting selected for
that you can sign up for my patreon for
$3 a month you'd also be receiving
access to my back catalog of bonus
videos which spans back a year and
covers a variety of topics all right bye
now